loved ones came together for a vigil  tonight to honor a man killed in a  shooting thursday afternoon  family identified the man killed as 23  year old andrey contreras  police say he was outside watching two  men fight when a friend of one of those  men showed up with a gun  that man was with the gun shot someone  fighting and the two bystanders  contreras died while a second victim in  critical condition  and a third is expected to survive  police are still looking for those  responsible  i get it they're all gonna fight i mean  once they bring guns out they take  innocent lives away  my son was just a bystander and all this  and his  life was cut short the family is working  to put together a car wash fundraiser  this weekend  in honor of andy